Film Courage: How much time today in 2018
do you dedicate to writing?
Gordy Hoffman, Screenwriter/Founder of Blue
Cat Screenplay Competition:
I don’t write in a disciplined way in a
timing thing a certain hour of the day, every
single day, Monday through Friday or anything
like that.
I’m one of those guys who writes in bunches
and writes at certain times of the day.
or writes in certain times.
There are certain days that I don’t write.
I wrote five pages this morning.
I did not do that for the benefit of the Film
Courage interview.
I was just like yesterday I need to, I’m
rewriting this thing and I’ve been going
around and around with it and I’ve started
really different approach on this script.
There are two projects that I’m working
on right now both of them to direct and both
of them have gone through a lot of different
development and there are people involved,
producers and stuff.
And I want to make one of them next year so
I really need to…I found myself bored…getting
really frustrated with this one thing and
I’m at this point where I don’t know if
I can figure this thing out and I was like
“You’ve got to hang in there.”
And I did and then I came in for a way to
open it again.
So I wrote a page on Friday.
I had this idea for the opening so I wrote
a page.
And then today I wrote four more pages so
I’m on page 5 and then I sent it over to
my staff (I send my pages in) and they kind
of take a look at them and give me quick feedback
to make sure I’m going in the right direction
or something like that.
And then this afternoon I’m going to go
to the other project where I’m outlining
it because it’s a heist and so I have to
do a lot of architecture stuff…It’s like
“Aarghh” Whereas this other thing is very
much like a LOVE LIZA where there’s a protagonist
and they’re on a mission kind of thing and
it’s that kind of a piece.
So it’s very much an extension of LOVE LIZA
but in that structurally, that character arc
kind of thing but I’ going to be directing
it.
Film Courage: You mentioned getting bored
and so when you get that signal that nothing
is happening, what’s your process?
Gordy: You cannot abandon it.
Every script…if you get bored with it, that
means you’re actually getting somewhere
with the movie.
People are amateurs primarily because they
can’t get through the professional period
of hating what they’re writing, bored, frustrated,
looking at every page going “I hate all
these scenes.”
I’m like “Ugh!”
There’s no magic here, I’m not enjoying
myself, it’s not gratifying.
So you have to suck it up and get through
that period, you can’t go…”Oh, I’m
bored.”
You are just going to go right back to where
that point is again.
There is a famous quote from Kurosawa about
this that I look at this almost every single
day (the quote) you should put it up with
this video because people will probably ask
about what it is but he talks about every
script falling into despair and he uses the
word despair and despair is a strong word
but it’s exactly what that is.
It’s like I can’t figure this out, I don’t
know how to figure this out, and I really
want to start with this because this other
thing, I know what to do with it, I’m going
to start it, not knowing or not remembering
that everything you write, you come to that
place of despair.
The artist, the writer, the director, the
actor (whatever) has to walk through that
period of desert period of the creative process
or they are not going to…or something will
click.
And that’s what happened is I hung in there
with this one thing where I was like “Oh
my God,” and then I came up with an image
and then I got some input from somebody (just
life experience) and I had some incident and
I was like “What if I move it and I started
over there?
And I do that.”
And then all the sudden I had an idea and
I was like “This is how it is.”
And I cracked my problem and I was like “Okay,
I’m back in the saddle.
I’ve got this thing going.
Now I can incorporate the other things I’ve
been working on that I like but I got through
that period of discouragement.
Film Courage: So when you know you’re in
that boredom, that you have a ritual for?
Gordy: It’s not a ritual.
A ritual is staying patient.
People don’t have any patience.
Corporate structures I think don’t allow
for patience when they’re making studio
pictures and stuff.
When they announce a release date and the
script is not done, well that’s counter
intuitive actually because it’s like “I’m
going to show you this but I haven’t written
it yet.”
That creates dysfunction.
So that’s why I think a lot of bets are
off and that’s why you have projects not
really work out.
You go to a movie, you go to the theater and
you’re like “What just happened in there?”
And it’s very difficult because it really
eliminates the principle of patience because
you’re not going to be like Well, let’s
pump the breaks.
This thing needs like 6 more months, I’ve
got to figure this out.
Can we move this release date back for a year
and a half?
And tell the Disney stockholders that the
STAR WARS movie is not going to come out for
4 years because we want to make sure the script
is good.
That’s not going to work and that’s okay.
It doesn’t mean that you can’t…I mean
the guys who wrote CASABLANCA, you can write
under duress and it can be successful.
Having deadlines and structure is fine.
But overall when you are stuck, having patience
and being like “Do not give up.
Do not relent.
Hang in there.”
And don’t change gears and I did and it
was a couple of weeks and it was a little
bit of time and I was kind of like “No,
no, no…Just keep hanging in there.”
And I was just like “What can you do here?
You have to hang in there.”
There is noting platable about working on
this script at all.
You want to start working on something else.
There are so many ideas that are so much sexier
or attractive that you want to jump into but
it’s like you can’t let go of this.
You have to hang in there.
So whatever the process is doesn’t matter,
it’s just exhibiting patience and realizing
if you hang in there the path is going to
open up according to Kurosawa and then the
path will open up and you’ll go “Ahh!”
And a lightbulb will go off and that’s what’s
happened with everything really.
Film Courage: APOCALYPSE NOW you don’t want
it to become your HEART OF DARKNESS.
Did you see the documentary?
It’s excellent.
Gordy: Yes I did but I think if anything what
Coppola was doing with APOCALYPSE NOW was
having patience and hanging in there because
a lot of places you want to give up but you
have to fight, a lot of places where you have
to fight through and maintaining that you
have to tell the truth, I want to be original,
I want to be compelling, I want to make imaginative
choices because to get through the darkness
you’re bored or your stuck because you’re
not giving up and you’re not compromising.
You’re not saying “Well, let’s just
shoot it anyways.
It’s good enough.
It’s already done.
Let’s just do it.
It’s good enough.
It doesn’t have to be perfect.”
I had a filmmaker say to me once “Gordy,
it doesn’t have to be perfect.”
And it’s like “You’re right.
It’s never going to be perfect.”
But what it’s implying is a little bit of
disregard of “Who cares?”
If you know something is kind of crap, or
it’s not believable or it’s not logical
or it’s not vulnerable or it isn’t clear
or whatever.
If you’re aware of problems but you’re
like “Well, who cares?
Then you’re not going to make someone’s
favorite movie that way.”